in a lengthy press conference in Lima on
Saturday Dino baluarte defended her
10-day-old presidency
resign what does my resignation solve
does it solve the problem it doesn't we
will be here firmly until Congress
decides to bring forward the elections
she's in a precarious position leader of
Peru only after ex-president Pedro
Castillo was impeached and detained she
was his vice president and many now want
her out and elections she's tried to
oblige proposing a date December 2023
but the country's heavily unpopular
Congress has voted against moving the
vote forward it's currently scheduled
for 2026.
meanwhile there have been more than 20
deaths as protests have spread
buluwati's government has declared a
state of emergency the Army's been
brought onto the streets and it was
noticeable that the first person to
speak after her in the press conference
was a general Romanos Elementos bad
individuals are moving from violent
actions to terrorist actions which are
punishable at the highest levels of
national law the critics say that the
government's made a concerted effort to
criminalize protests
and on Saturday even as buluwati spoke
of peace and peruvians coming together
anti-terrorist police were raiding the
headquarters of an opposition party and
a farmer organization
more than 20 indigenous farmers were
held opposition party leaders told us
our colleagues are being interrogated
and they want to take them to the
anti-terrorism center it's really
worrying and evidence of how the
government is trying to convince the
population that peaceful protests are
acts of terrorism
an indignant crowd turned up to try and
free them
[Music]
you see the police line here to try and
stop them so images like this one that
are sending alarm bells ringing about
growing authoritarianism in the country
the only way forward for a country in
crisis seems to be elections now it's
congress's turn to decide if they're
brought forward and if the country can
move on with new leaders John Holman Al
Jazeera Lima